two roads
this is the story of two girls from a
rural town in Central America who left
that town together to seek a new life
it is the story of a time when they
reached a Crossroads and of the two
roads they took from that point
is the story of Consuelo in Yolanda
and now it is Yolanda story
the Green Hills and the cornfields are
the scenes of my childhood
coming back is like coming home but so
much has happened between then and now
that it's like coming back from a far
country
after the city The Village seemed so
quiet and simple
I can remember when life in such a
village seemed too dull to be endured
but I have come here willingly
because I think the heart of my country
is here and I belong here
thank you
the clinic I was seeking was only a
short distance away I was eager to begin
the new job and the new life
[Music]
that girl she could be Consuelo two
girls on the way to the city with
everything before them
oh I remember I remember
[Music]
it was all so exciting so different and
new we were lucky certainly our parents
had agreed to give us this chance
although they really could not afford it
to go to the Capitol to school
perhaps we had argued so strongly and so
successfully because we argued together
as we had always done everything
together
I was going to be an auxiliary nurse
part of a new program maybe someday a
real nurse
Consuelo was going to be a secretary
maybe someday a businesswoman the city
held the key to everything for us
[Music]
from the start Ila killed we borrowed an
apartment for a while from my cousins
while they were traveling and we settled
in quickly
for me it was not as hard as I had
expected to become a city person it was
easy to become accustomed to little
luxuries
for Consuelo it was as though all her
life had been preparation to come to the
Capitol and be a real City Girl
we'd see how it worked out
when I was chosen for the auxiliary
nurse course program from our village I
had no idea how much I would need to
learn but I loved it all with Consuelo
it was different I think
[Music]
Yolanda
the new haircut produced our first real
argument because I like it better the
way it was softer and simpler Consuelo
taunted me for being old-fashioned she
had picked a new role for herself
something out of magazines and
television and was determined to play it
foreign
she was like a child who wanted to
become an adult overnight without taking
time to grow up
[Music]
she loved the shops and the chance to
look Chic and cool like the girls in the
magazines
I play myself because I saw all the
early signs of Consuelo's foolishness
and did not react to them
because she wasn't she had always been
to me sweet and funny and full of life
foreign
[Music]
ER Cafe near our apartment just for a
lark for a soda and to look at the
streets and the people
maybe we'll see somebody new today she'd
say
[Music]
our mothers would have been horrified
of course the world has changed since
they were young in many ways
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think that nothing in Consuelo's life
had prepared her for an experience like
Juan Carlos
he was So Graceful so easy as though
Nothing in life could ever really be a
problem for him
the cinema actors are sometimes that way
shiny smooth like something made of
glass
I remembered the village boys who used
to try to attract Consuelo's attention
they were like a different species
thank you
the Consuelos of this world were all
armed with knowledge of themselves and
their minds and bodies they would be
less vulnerable
unhappily unless they have been exposed
to careful and honest education about
their own sexuality they know almost
nothing
they take their emotional guidelines
from television Cinema and magazines and
in time even the best of their childhood
guidelines diminish in strength and
Authority
they enter the alien country of romantic
love defenseless fragile and Confused
Consuelo Consuelo's evenings at home
with me became rarer and rare I asked
her about her progress in school but she
put me off in truth she was not a
serious student
she hated the drudgery of study and
could not agree with me that she needed
to study every night in order to
complete her courses
I worried that if she failed all the
money her parents had spent would be
wasted and she could not possibly get
the kind of job she wanted
but she saw her playtime encounters with
Juan Carlos as a real and important
experience of life
said and probably believed
it's like a door opening for me
one part of our nursing training was a
study of human sexuality
I thought I knew a little about it but I
was surprised to find I knew almost
nothing
and it was a shock to find out how many
things I thought I knew were myths
for example the professor told us any
time after a woman is fully developed
that is has started her menstrual period
any Act of intercourse can result in a
pregnancy
how often I have heard girls say you
can't get pregnant the first time see
but in fact you can the professor said
any girl who is fully developed can
become pregnant as a result of any
intercourse I was anxious to share some
of this new knowledge with Consuelo
English
Consuelo is always was in a hurry and
concentrating only on making herself
beautiful for Juan Carlos
I'd love to hear about it she said but
some other time I'm running a little
late
I very much needed to know whether she
and Juan Carlos were serious and she
would only tell me how wonderful he was
but are you really seriously involved I
asked her
she hesitated but said yes
I was sorry to pry
but was by now truly concerned
you need to think about these things to
protect yourself if you are really
involved with one Carlos don't count on
this wonderful fellow to take care of
everything
and at this she was angry
Yolanda don't worry about me I can take
care of myself
but I wasn't so sure that she could
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in time
I began to realize that we were no
longer walking along the same road
she had moved too far away for me to
reach
and I was not strong enough to be wise
for both of us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and then one day
Consuelo met me with the news I suppose
I had feared all along
it is such an old old story
one Wonders that it still happens with
all we have learned about preparation
and prevention
after all the good reasons physical
spiritual practical
why it should not happen like this
when I asked her once more are you
absolutely sure you're pregnant
doctor says that I am
oh Yolanda what am I going to do
what indeed what could I tell you
now except of course one thing she must
tell Juan Collins
but that she feared to do
I told him what is surely true the
responsibility is with two persons not
just with her she had to tell him and
soon
she had been so sure she could take care
of herself
foreign
it was my turn to be strong and Stern no
matter how I pitied her
because she and Juan Carlos both of them
would have to face the reality of the
situation and reach a decision
and she said I'll try to talk to him
and I said not try you must talk to him
unless you're afraid to
there was nothing for it but that you
should tell Juan Carlos appeal to him of
course they should and probably could
marry but would they
was she ready to stop right now to
become a wife and mother
perhaps more importantly was he ready
to become a husband and father
in five years perhaps but now
the sexuality of the very young is a
condition as old as humankind
it is something inside Nature's
mysterious plan for all of us
it is a sad and Universal corollary that
sexuality grows more quickly than wisdom
more quickly than even a simple Instinct
for self-preservation
so when it lasts Consuelo Met Juan
Carlos with the agonized admission that
she was indeed pregnant she was greeted
with a cruel but common question
are you sure it's mine he
of course it's yours you are the only
one
what now
well of course Consuelo thought they
could get married
married no no way this might have been
predicted the personal scenario Juan
Carlos has developed for his life does
not call for marriage so soon
certainly not to a pretty foolish
Village girl
Juan Carlos may not be ready for
marriage but this is not unfamiliar
territory
we know someone who can handle these
matters
he will telephone her
so in the end she was left alone
as young girls have been left alone in
such circumstances all over the world
all through time
actually what are her options
she could bear the baby and take it back
to her Village
she could add the care of a child to the
burdens of her parents
they had already sacrificed to give her
training which would fit her to take a
job
and she had neglected her training for
parties and dancing
of course your parents would take her in
with her child
but what kind of life could she give
that child without skills or money
[Music]
and yet the alternative the solution
proposed by Juan Carlos seemed too
terrible
why had she said to herself
it won't happen to me
[Music]
why does any young girl in love say it
won't happen to me
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I returned home the following day
I found Consuelo in bed terribly ill
Consuelo what is it
and she told me the Dreadful news
she had had an abortion yeah
okay
thank you
that had been Juan Carlos response to
her appeal
she was feverish Delirious some sudden
infection who knew what
Consuelo
I got her to the hospital
but she lived less than a day
and I never heard her laughing voice
again
[Music]
and now here I am back in a village
a long way along that other Road
I will help the health center nurse and
work toward the job myself
and there will never be a day when I do
not Wonder
if I could have changed anything
if I had known two years ago what I know
today
[Music]
I was not much older than the little
servant girl when I first decided to
become a nurse see
it before
foreign
[Music]
she did not quite accept me at first
perhaps because I still had not changed
my City clothes and City ways
but she would help me to come home to
this small world of the village
this will be my life now
the names on these cards will be my
people
perhaps another Consuela will come to me
someday and give me a chance to help her
before it is too late
to tell her
don't try to grow up too soon
if you fall in love be very sure you are
ready to take care of a baby and make a
home for it
before you begin that baby
don't try to live life all at once
there will be years ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you